- Feel like busting lip,
feel like busting Liz.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Hi Evelyn.
- Hi Jasper.
- [Interviewer] Welcome back,
it's nice to see you again.
- Very nice.
- [Interviewer] I found you
on the streets, yet again.
- Ah, ta ta
- [Interviewer] It's a
beautiful day in San Francisco,
in the Tenderloin.
- Yes it is.
One time I was in a rest
home, and my family left me.
and as I entered the restaurant,
a ball of flame came
behind the glass doors.
And, I said, no socks no service.
And my birthday was the
next day, so I went back
to the rest home.
And my family pulled in.
And we went for a waterfall walk.
So, I saw a girl in a bikini,
and
I think it was my brother-in-law, or maybe
they knew it was me, as
they looking towards me.
Said, "nice tan"
and a bear climbed in the water.
And took a towel and strangled the goat
by pulling it on its horns.
So, I said hide the hoe,
and my family wouldn't
let me back in the car
because I used the word hoe.
And my brother yells out the window,
she's not a prostitute.
And the way he said it
and the way I took it
was 200 years apart.
So my mom takes a roll of
toilet paper and sticks
it out the window, and it
rolls around the antenna
and they have a 10 lbs
block of cheese, on the hood
of the car.
And I said going down
the road, sure enough
the ferning of the car is lifted.
And they ran into a motor home.
Which was sister had
rented to towel of it.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn
can I ask you a question?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about
the great loves of your life.
- Oh, Trevor.
- [Interviewer] No I mean like,
maybe the people in your life.
- Fresh fruit.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
what about the men?
Have you been in love before?
- No, I never have.
- [Interviewer] Never?
I've been active.
- [Interviewer] You were married?
- Yeah, I was married to
Shakespear for seven years.
- [Interviewer] And how was that?
- He was leather.
His voice went out.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn, what
are you proudest of your life?
- Finishing college.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Where
did you go to school?
- Manhattan.
Princeton, for piano.
Yale for running.
Hunter for science.
And I saw Einstein.
And I was reading a book, and
it took me a long time to get a brain
that would stay captive,
I was in love with
Indian law, that's all I had.
I had been a young girl, and I was very
um, petite in the muscle area,
That gets stretched.
So I didn't know about they signed me up
for Olympic training.
And I came out and a child
pushed me from behind.
And I kicked his head and I didn't know
I was so strong.
That my mother,
was born in 1940.
And he started crying.
And I said I'm not gonna
do anything, he said
"do something."
So I got my,
my finger out and
I threw a ball and it hit a boy
in the, eye.
And a teacher came over
and said, "we're gonna make
a tortures chamber for you,
little girl you apologize."
I said I repent and I went
to the front of the school
I said, "torture?"
So I was just on a river walk
he just had monopoly money
and he wanted me and he
said, why am I queer today
and a bus went behind him.
And it stopped, and it didn't, didn't um
honk its horn.
And I said um, why don't we
go get a square fruit cake?
And he said, " oh you
mean that sugarless gum?"
And I bend over and he
disappears behind the gate
and boards the bus.
And waves to me from the
window it's pulled down
about an inch, I go "bye bye, baby"
he goes "you're too
skinny for sugarless gum."
I know that was pretty
good for monopoly money
on a river block.
You're too skinny for sugarless gum,
he knew his worth.
Turned out to be a fire department's plug.
One of the fire department
had ripped his eyelid
on a tree.
Coming down to the catalogue market.
I left them my ink printer
but we didn't have any toner.
So I turned myself in for um, child abuse.
Because I left a baby
in a uh, safety section
on death row.
This was when land was
very small, we just had uh
a walk through a concrete
block, it was freezing cold.
There was even rain
dripping from the ceiling
people lying to the side,
cuts on their eyebrows.
Their fingers and whole
arms displayed on concrete.
One arm was stepped on and
yelped and closed his eye
and I bent over, to
awaken him and to save him
and bring him a block of reality.
And they cuffed me and
used their knight sticks
he put it up the sleeve up my slack.
So when they did that, I didn't object
and immediately I was on the
stand here stay platform.
Singing the train coming.
And I bent over to look
at it and the conducter
grabbed me by the back of the collar.
And he said, "why don't
you go get some matches?"
And I went, around thinking
that I was in the subway.
And I went in front of Burger King.
And the man was taking
hit after hit of pot
striking match after match.
I said that makes 16.
And the cops walked up behind me,
I said you're not cop
until you've seen this.
Man making food disorientation.
And they, they said
this place doesn't have
a food license.
And they closed it that night.
And I said, 'well, um, I
prefer not to starve to death."
If you could walk me out
to the fire department,
and it took us five hours
and fourteen minutes.
And I said, "I'm gonna sit down here."
And the concrete was soaking wet.
And they came over to
me and they were naked
except for underpants.
I said "why don't we go down to the park?"
and we did.
And they pulled out a beauty kit.
They filed my nails, told
me why it wasn't necessary
to flush the toilet.
That the wells was 35 feet deep.
And that they were national
geographics photographers.
The day had seen me last
get dipping my hands
into assets.
To save the raincoat.
My sister had slept too late.
She had opened a
pneumonia tank with a key,
and she denied it.
But when I threw an orange into a box
to make a boyfriend for
myself, the NBA coach
walked up behind me and
said, "the dogs are ready
with popeye fish."
And he fell in and his chin
was hanging from the dock.
And I said, "I'll marry you if
you show me my two fingers."
And, I almost fell in but
I was trembling from behind
I said, "Evelyn, when he
gets up you can work at any
job site you want."
And I did, I got a job that day.
In an Alaskan bar called, uh, Peach
Peach Whistle stop cafe.
And I met Sally Renn,
she circled the Earth
with monkeys.
She landed in the Florida keys.
Uh, I also met Chad
Eithenhower, a hydroplane driver
he drives on water.
And, um, Bonnie Lake
and Bonnie Riot were also in the bar.
And they were walked me through a concrete
uh, block of not telling
much, you know how the army
uh, the berets, they walked
me through the berets of
1939, when Hitler
surrendered to the Japanese
and, and Paris.
And he couldn't speak French
and when he stopped talking, Russia did
what Russia was may,
they only speak to people
who look 17.
It doesn't matter if
you tell them their age,
they'll just go "huh?"
You go back to work.
- [Interviewer] So Evelyn,
what were your high school
years like, what kind
of teenager were you?
- I was a smelly cat.
People said I had body odor.
I was very nervous, I wanted
to be a cook very bad.
But I just had a halty
top, it was really cute
my first day of high school.
My sister had been nearly
killed being thrown
out of a car.
But I learned three days
later that she didn't
know the word, road.
But I spread the word
that day, I said we've got
to be careful about speeding cars.
And everybody says, "oh yeah,
we can't go to high school."
So we all got the giggles and we ran out
we became cheerleaders
that wear short uniforms
I was the only one dressed in black.
They said, "Evelyn get up
and show us what you can do."
And I said, "oh I'm not tan enough."
They said, "oh, you know
what Eddie Murke is riding
up to the mountains today."
And I ran home, I said
I've gotta be all alone
so I can write what I
wanna be when I turn into
Olympians.
And my dad says uh,
"remember when we had pizza?"
He says, "I've got
another big one for you."
And my brother walked in,
was a christmas tree and he
said, " I just bought a house."
Is the potato salad ready?
And he said, "I'm so glad
you're home, Evelyn."
And he handed me a
money order, and he said
"dad bought a golf set
with his um, money."
I said FDA warned you that
this is a jurisdiction,
and he left house screaming and crying.
And he said, " God, she's
a cop I thought she was
a US marine."
And he sticks his tongue out the window
and my mom comes over,
and she had a rifle.
And I said, "man that's a leg."
That's what I learned
in the marine that year.
If you keep going like this
eventually, you'll make a gun,
because your legs will clap
fast, and you'll keep talking.
Or the window will bust.
And so he drove out in
his BMW and he came back
four hours later, and he said,
"Evelyn I wanna marry you
I'm gonna do it or give
me that money order back."
So I got in the backseat of the volkswagen
and I was really decided that
I had to live as a waitress.
And I said "Jim can you
drive me up the road
and drop me off?"
And I chest out a video
and there was a woman
lying like this and I was
attracted to the dress.
And I brought the video
tape home and it was of
a girl walking behind a scene,
and suddenly the, the
tape turns into the USS
with people dancing on it.
And, so now, I was in the Cadillac hotel
oh the um, uh
the Sunny side hotel.
It's a boys youth home.
It turned into that one night.
Finally got the manager to
stop giving away bribes.
He would tell people to
go get coffee for him,
he was, uh, on the verge of knocking out
from food poisoning.
Because the pizza was the only thing that
San Francisco had and I
didn't dream to follow it.
So, I didn't have any
problem, I was pushing
and pushing my pipe.
So this morning I was
woken up with a thrush.
That's a fight that you don't win, to me
you not liking people,
you don't want to wake up.
And I heard a boy say, " go
ahead and get up, they gonna
belt you in."
And soon after I took
the belt off, I stuck it
under a disco dance garage.
Somebody had looped a belt around me neck
trying to murder me.
I never found out who they were.
But I had come down from uh,
hotel with a cup of coffee.
He asked me not to take it.
And as I went out the
door with the coffee cup,
soon enough, somebody, bam
a leather belt around my
neck and they hooked it too
when they closed the door
they was no screen on there.
So, as my first jacket was just 6 dollars,
I got a whole 6 dollars I didn't
know to renumerate to bank
during the the color years.
You know these banks would,
be stuck with young people
eating vegetable pie and
um, nibbling on all day
on pizza.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn?
- Yeah?
- [Interviewer] What's your
favorite childhood memory?
- Oh finding a size that
house open when I could
peek through a house.
Was saying a mince cat.
Full fur.
That was the most fur
that I've ever descended.
There was a man below the well,
that well was 15 feet deep.
He had been in there for 5 days.
Somebody had mowed the
bath lawn and built a house
with lumber.
This was back when there was free land.
And I stepped on a nail when I was young.
So I was put on life support.
In, in Isreal hospital, they
had flown me by helicopter
this was the year before
Vietnam war ended.
So I guess they wouldn't
let communism go there.
Go anywhere near, even Americans.
They feared the word.
And I said, "would you
rather be a racist?"
And I started my bike
and I rode for 13 hours.
And I stopped on the railway tracks
and soon enough a train
went by, choo choo choo
and I walked through it, my
mom was on the other side,
So was my little sister.
Her zipper had been zipped up to her chin.
She had also been taken
to a hospital but she
had been like that for 7 hours.
Just cuddling your throat,
and when they unzipped it
boy did she cry.
She was trembling, she's
still a very shaky girl
but she doesn't talk much
she fears the human voice
but, she's friends with Brooke Shields
I had met her on a bus, she
had a bandaid on her knee
and we both got our,
our photograph taken by
Richard Drifest.
And a gang member, Julie got off
she over rates her cream.
So I met her as a waitress
and she put her plate down
on a, on a, she's a
waitress so a food server.
But she is a glaton where as I am
old fart with gassy legs.
But anyway my hamstrench
are short, so I can
stretch and jump.
And I said " 5 inches
will get you a mile."
And soon after she kicked
the king in the hip.
I said "he is the king forgetting so your
abusive mother syndrome."
I said, "you know I have to be a mother."
She said "I used to grow
pot but they busted me
on the old folks home."
I said "oh that is so funny."
And they served me a,
uh, a watermelon juice
and uh, I guess his hip
was against the bar stool
cause when he sat up there was a hamburger
and a fried mushroom and that
was on my dinner for 7 days.
As I dated Carlos Carlos my father-in-law.
His son is a welder.
Up in Portland. He also grows weed and
Mary picks cotton, she was with me
it was just the two of us,
in a rap bar in Savanna Georgia.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn?
- Yeah?
- [Interviewer] Who's
your favorite beetle?
- Paul McCartney.
Paul McCartney cause he does
photography and he's married
to Linda.
She doesn't have a last name.
She's famous too in, in music circles.
She's very light skinned
so you can't see her unless
you're, you know how
sensitive are security guards
she, she likes to read too,
she also paints in oils.
She was born in a matisse painting.
I was at the good Bok museum
my first afternoon in New York
knowing I had college.
And I was yelling down the street
I said, "may I join
you?" Across the street.
And a girl punched me in
the face and broke my jaw.
And so I said, what should I do
said, "Evelyn you are a
marine, you got information
flowing through your arms."
I said you need some seeze
so I found a pomegranate
and I ate half of it
and I felt this spine sparkling
and I met a um, endophine
that's somebody who's uh, um
you're in a big city with a big career
anyway he was a clown, so he
tried to teach me to juggle
and I spent 5 days on the trapoquite hall
the land was very small
it was about 2 inches long
that was the first lane
when I ate that pomegranate
before that people had to
walk on water certain beds
and um, so anyway, this
man had been underground
for 5 days and when I got
up, I saw his rib cage
he was naked and didn't
have any, sperm count
and so, I stuck my finger up his bowbun
and that became the king's abusive mother.
So she's a queer.
I walked her out, I find
her friend I tell her
the king is out of beer stock.
But um, you know, we
had since been swept up
in the head 6 times, but, you know
she was underground for 5 days.
So he may never know that
being is, she did hit him
5 times in the stool channel.
♪ Road red wine, stay
close to me this time ♪
♪ I don't want to be all alone ♪
♪ I'm busting my head ♪
♪ I got the blues, red
wine made me feel so fine ♪
♪ Red red wine make me feel so fine ♪
♪ I'm on the pine all the time ♪
♪ You got the blues. ♪
- [Interviewer] I love it when you sing
- Thank you.
Yeah, I did major in singing that's why
I moved to New York.
My father's from Rachester
had some rivages since
into that town.
I walked there on a, um,
field block to get my license
to teach.
And soon after I said, I
was in the Dallas airport.
It was just uh, four seat long.
And I ran, I ran and I
busted my breasts on the door
and I stood there.
And I said, "stop
trembling this gotta me."
And I went like this, I
remember cannot working
in Canada.
Soon after it was a mall,
and I went shopping there
with a the 10 dollars
the king had given me
for sharing my watermelon
juice, it was him.
He still doesn't eat meat.
He drinks beer, fresh water
yeah he's the only blast
man I know who likes water.
And barbran, he cooks me
out half a pound of cocaine
this morning.
He sucks on it.
A lot of people do it too, cocaine
I smoke it on the pot
cause, I just have a uh, uh
because I just do not
have a, I see appearance
I don't like that.
But I am from a cool climate.
But I was invited to
Hawaii because they needed
a receptionist for a Bondello.
They, I knew what sex was
until the time I was till
I had my eyes wide open
but, I just had one
slick order gland but
they gave me all the sugar
I wanted.
They were so lonely and,
but we were using sugar
because uh, that was when
slave ships were running
and gasoline was free.
You can grab candy bars
and, but my favorite was
jim dandy to the rescue
my father bought halloween candy with his,
he signed up to be a judge before that
he was unemployed on
verge of his break down.
He slept in high stack
when he was 7 years old.
And had to wand his land,
landing up as a female
with a dress on.
He's, he preaches.
One of his sons, uh, I
guess he's in college
my brother Jerry, my mom
's uh, brother had a son
and she adopted him and
quote papers when my sister
was married, and came home from
she went to school in Arizona
yeah, she's an accountant for the IRS.
She does tax filing.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn, are
you, are you good for today,
you wanna take a break?
- [Evelyn} Yes Sir.
- [Interviewer] That was fun.
- [Evelyn] Okay, thank you.
- [Interviewer] I love hearing you sing.
- [Evelyn] Thanks, can we
get back in the car now?
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- [Evelyn] Okay, thank you.
- [Interviewer] And be back.
- Sure.
♪ You got the blues ♪
♪ Red red wine make me feel so fine ♪
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] I love your singing.